[Musica]
buonasera e ebbene sì la storia che vi
racconto non è una storia tanto a buon
fine perché è un po la storia della
nostra vita e della storia di come il
tempo passa sono sicuro che molti di voi
si saranno chiesti ma quanto tempo vivrò
io e se voi guardate le statistiche sono
veramente impressionanti una persona che
nasceva nell'antica roma aveva
un'aspettativa di vita di 22 anni
questo vuol dire che più di 50 per cento
delle persone non ce la facevano oltre
questo periodo di tempo ovviamente una
statistica molto inficiata dall alta
mortalità alla nascita subito dopo la
nascita ma se guardiamo anche il
novecento meno di 50 anni 49 anni e poi
un grande salto all'inizio del 2000 26
anni abbiamo guadagnato più di 25 anni
soltanto in un secolo e queste sono le
ultime statistiche dell'organizzazione
mondiale della sanità i primi dieci
posti nella statistica noi in italia
siamo al sesto posto adesso 82 84.8 di
sopravvivenza per le femmine 80.5 per
l'uomo quindi più di 80 anni per per
entrambi i sessi stiamo andando
andando molto bene guadagnato ancora
moltissimo rispetto a soltanto una
decina di anni fa ma se voi immaginate
un mondo perfetto in cui la medicina
cura tutte le malattie in cui le
malattie infettive sono prevenuto dei
vaccini in cui il cancro non esiste in
cui gli incidenti vengono riparati in
cui tutto funziona in maniera perfetta
saremmo immortali e purtroppo la
risposta è no
noi abbiamo da qualche parte scritto
nella nostra informazione genetica
un'informazione che fa sì che tutti i
membri della specie homo sapiens quindi
noi viviamo un massimo di 120 125 anni
ed è un informazione genetica
strettissima con volo è strettissima per
tutto quello che vive sul pianeta terra
un popolo vive due anni un ratto vive
tre una pecora vive 12 anni le
tartarughe vivono a lungo 150 anni
moscerino della frutta quello che si usa
nel laboratorio quello che si trova
sulla cima frutta che mangiamo quando
informarci aviv e tre mesi c'è un
programma biologico e quindi genetico
scritto da qualche parte che determina
aspettativa di vita massima e noi non
abbiamo assolutamente idea di dove sia
questo programma non sappiamo rispondere
alla domanda perché un topo vive due
anni il nuovo vive 120 quando
condividono più dell 85 per cento
dell'informazione genetica o il motivo è
molto semplice in realtà la nostra
evoluzione la nostra permanenza sul
pianeta non è dettata dalla selezione
naturale sul nostro organismo è dettata
dalla selezione naturale sui nostri geni
quindi noi siamo semplicemente delle
macchine biologiche che devono
trasmettere la nostra informazione
genetica la nostra progenie quindi
quando la nostra progenia è a sua volta
autonoma per trasmettere questi
informate nei propri figli e noi la
specie umana se molti rimasti anche un
po più in vita per vedere anche i nostri
nipoti ecco che allora non serviamo più
sul pianeta quindi è giusto che
l'evoluzione ci faccia fuori perché non
diventiamo dei competitori dei nostri
figli dei nostri nipoti per l'accesso
alle risorse sul pianeta
non sappiamo dove stia l'inghippo però
sappiamo sicuramente qualcosa che mentre
noi invecchiamo si vanno esaurire e
forse proprio questa la causa
dell'invecchiamento si vanno esaurire
quelle che sono le capacità di
riparazione e rigenerazione della
maggior parte dei nostri organi tessuti
cellule immaginate che noi abbiamo una
barriera fissa un muro fisso
invalicabile e progressivamente con la
medicina con l'alimentazione condizione
igieniche stiamo avvicinando sia questo
muro e mentre ci avviciniamo questo muro
esauriamo le risorse di riparazione dei
nostri organi e tessuti per esempio
prendete il cuore voi potete prendere il
cuore di un paziente di un individuo
normale come di un topo potete prendere
adulto prendete le sue cellule del cuore
le mettete in laboratorio troverete
queste magnifiche cellule che non sono
una specie di mattoncini molto lunghi
alcuni hanno due nuclei che sono queste
in blu in questa diapositiva le
striature sono l'apparato che consente
alla cellula di contrarsi ritmicamente
70 volte al minuto
potete tenere il laboratorio potete
studiarle potesse farci tutti quegli
studi non riuscirete mai
secondo le tecnologie attuali almeno
fino a un paio d'anni fa a farle
riprodurre cioè noi nasciamo
con un numero di cellule del nostro
cuore e queste sono le stesse cellule
con cui poi andremo a morire quando la
nostra vita si sarà esaurita pensate
fantastico pensare delle cellule che per
miliardi di volte si contraggono
ritmicamente in una persona di 70 anni
ma sono esattamente le stesse con cui
queste persone era nata col cervello
andiamo ancora peggio perché le cellule
del cervello smettono di replicarsi un
po prima della nascita addirittura noi
nasciamo con circa una cinquantina di
miliardi di cellule nel cervello e non
soltanto non si replicano human e
perdiamo circa 80.000 ogni giorno io
sono qua che parlo con voi voi mi
ascoltate
stiamo tutti perdendo cellule
possibilità di recupero di queste
cellule
assolutamente nessuna cioè quello che
succede è che tutti noi siamo figli di
un ovocita lucide nostra madre lo
spermatozoo di nostro padre
la fecondazione di questa uscita da
parte dello spermatozoo da origine della
prima cellula dell'organismo in biologia
si chiamano zygote poi questa cellula
diventa 2 diventa 4 diventa 8 diventa 16
dopo 4 5 giorni dalla fecondazione una
sferetta di circa 150 cellule si chiama
blastocisti e poi queste cellule
cominciano a specializzarsi per un
organismo adulto come voi come me
contiene circa 100 mila miliardi di
cellule diverse ciascuno con una
specializzazione una falla cellule del
cuore un affare del neurone una falla
c'è il globulo bianco una falla cielo
della pelle una falce lo della retina ci
sono circa 240 tipi di specializzazioni
diverse ma alcune di queste cellule non
si replicheranno mai più cool e della
cute continuano un po replicarsi durante
tutta la vita all e dell'intestino
quelle del sangue lo fanno ma leggero
del cuore 90 del cervello novel cellule
del pancreas
nola il cervello del maggior parte degli
organi non lo fanno
e allora se voi avete un po questa
visione vi stupite che ci sia questa
enorme diffusione delle malattie
degenerative pensate soltanto al morbo
di alzheimer molo di alzheimer è dovuto
alla perdita di neuroni in particolare
tipo di neuroni nel cervello colpisce
una persona su tre dopo gli 80 anni
una persona su tre dopo gli 80 anni dopo
che vi ho appena detto che gli uomini
vivono più di 80 anni e le donne più di
85 anni
una vera epidemia mio amico e collega
negli stati uniti inizia i suoi seminari
guardando le persone chiedendo a
ciascuno di guardare chi seduto alla sua
sinistra che seduto alla sua destra e di
decidere chi di loro tre morirà di una
malattia cardiovascolare che questa è la
realtà 30 per cento delle persone
muoiono di una malattia cardiovascolare
che nella maggior parte dei casi è
dovuta all'incapacità del cuore di
rigenerarsi quindi di andare incontro a
riparazione nella vita adulta e invece
che di andare incontro a una malattia
che si chiama scompenso cardiaco 15
milioni di nuove diagnosi di scompenso
cardiaco
ogni anno nel mondo e dopo i 75 anni una
persona su tre non ci vede bene perché
ha avuto una degenerazione della retina
e la retina non si ripara una persona su
due dopo 65 anni non ci sente bene
perché ha avuto una degente generazione
quindi una perdita delle cellule
dell'orecchio interno la sordità e poi
cosa che noi associamo spontaneamente la
vecchiaia ma in realtà è una malattia
una malattia dovuta alle alfred di
cellule dall'incapacità di queste
cellule di replicarsi allora dobbiamo
trovare pezzi di ricambio pezzi di
ricambio vuol dire trovare
sostanzialmente cellule dove troviamo
ste cellule per riuscire a rigenerare
questi organi visto che spontaneamente
non ce la fanno
beh la cosa più ovvia e prenderle da un
embrione noi possiamo tranquillamente
come si fa nelle cliniche della
fertilità a prendere una cellula uovo
prendere uno spermatozoo fare la
fecondazione coltivare queste queste
embrione in laboratorio in provetta per
45 giorni finché forma questa sferetta
che scriva blastocisti poi la sferetta
viene disgregata le cellule che la
formano si chiamano cellule embrionali
staminali possono coltivarli
indefinitamente possono ottenere molti
molti miliardi e poi convincere queste
cellule a diventare una cellula
specializzata per esempio queste sono
delle cellule di un embrione di topo che
noi abbiamo fatto diventare delle
cellule di cuore vedete che anche in
laboratorio in provetta si contraggono
simultaneamente che una caratteristica
delle cellule del cuore noi prendiamo
queste cuore queste cellule le mettiamo
all'interno del cuore di un topolino
infartuato rigeneriamo completamente il
cuore
tutto bello tutto bello però di fatto
questo è molto problematico primo perché
ci vogliono
leone secondo perché secondo molte
eccezioni culturali religiose un
embrione se fosse impiantato darebbero
origine a una nuova vita quindi stiamo
distruggendo delle vite e terza poi
perché un embrione un un essere che dal
punto di vista della medicina è diverso
dal punto di vista immunologico cui
dovremmo trattare questo tipo di
trattamento come se fosse un trapianto
di reni al trapianto di cuore quindi
fare immunosoppressione con tutta una
serie di altri problemi quindi un
problema possiamo ottenere questi pezzi
di ricambio senza dover passare
attraverso la fertilizzazione di nuovo
senza dover passare attraverso un nuovo
e un uno spermatozoo e la risposta è
stata no fino al 1999 97 quando
improvvisamente un gruppo di veterinari
scozzesi pubblica su una delle
principali riviste internazionali un
esperimento che ha fatto scalpore
definito sui giornali che la creazione
della pecora dolly come stata fatta a
dolly stata fatta bypassando il processo
della fecondazione cioè prendendo un
uovo di una pecora donatrice e prendendo
una cellula adulta di un individuo da
cui è stata estratta l'informazione
genetica è stato preso il nucleo è
trasferito nel luogo in quel momento
quel nucleo di una cellula adulta di una
cena specializzata che non si replicava
più per qualche motivo ha pensato di
essere il prodotto di una fecondazione e
ha dato origine a un nuovo embrione
quindi ha tagliato completamente fuori
il problema della nella fecondazione
però chi di nuovo a una visione
religiosa della vita dice sì ma facendo
questo tool in realtà crei comunque uno
embrione che è comunque una blastocisti
se questa fosse impiantate io nutro
darebbe origine a una pecora dolly
quindi se lo facessi in un uomo questo
embrione potrebbe dare origine non
essere umano quindi non è che posso
trovare qualcosa che consente invece di
evitare completamente il problema degli
embrioni e di nuovo la risposta è stata
no per altri 10 anni finché nel 2006
questo signore che si chiama shinya
yamanaka che ha vinte premio nobel per
la medicina nel 2012 ha insegnato alla
comunità scientifica una maniera del
tutto rivoluzionaria per farlo io ho
detto io posso prendere una cellula di
qualsiasi individuo per esempio una
cielo della pelle una cellula del sangue
inserire all'interno di questa cellula
soltanto quattro geni e questi geni
convincono questa cellula diventare una
cellula dell'embrione
ecco che allora io posso coltivare
questa cellule dell'embrione ottenerne
molti miliardi convincere le diventare
una cellula di cuore per esempio
metterla nel cuore dopo infarto e
rigenerare il cuore qui non ci sono
embrioni non c'è possibilità di fare
nuovi esseri umani se la soluzione
sembra perfetta e un po in perfetta dal
punto di vista tecnico perché è molto
difficile ottenerlo soltanto quest'anno
un mese scorso
stai ripartita una sperimentazione in
giappone per cercare di rigenerare
l'occhio perché la tecnologia talmente
ancora non robusta e non consente di
fare grandi quantità di cellule per fare
il cuore il fegato o tantomeno il
cervello ma consente probabilmente di
fare un piccolo quantitativo di cellule
che potrebbe essere utile per rigenerare
la retina
ci potrebbero essere delle soluzioni
diverse cerchiamo di essere un po
immaginativi per esempio dobbiamo vedere
come fanno altri organismi ari generale
i propri organi per esempio se voi
prendete molti pesci uno di questi pesce
il pesce zebra del laboratorio zebra
fisso oppure le salamandre e voi potete
tagliare grandi porzioni del loro corpo
la coda le pinne fare un danno alla
retina fare danno un cuore e questi
generano spontaneamente
questo è un animaletto molto
interessante si chiama psol 8 perché un
nome un nome maya perché questo animale
vive sui vulcani spenti a 4000 metri del
messico del nicaragua un animale storico
bloccato allo stato larvale voi potete
prenderlo tagliare una sua zampa di
questa zampa nell'arco di 40 giorni
ricresce che spontaneamente mari cresce
spontaneamente in maniera completa
cresce come anatomia come ossa come
nervi come muscoli come dimensioni nel
potente tagliarla soltanto una volta per
far ricrescere potete tagliarla cento
volte cento volte questa zamp vi
ricrescerà questi animali hanno dentro
un programma biologico che consente a
loro di fare quello che noi mammiferi
sappiamo fare solo una volta nella vita
durante il nostro sviluppo embrionale
noi sappiamo fare
quarto ma non sappiamo rifarlo una volta
che questo è stato tagliato
come fanno a rigenerare questi animali
non lo fanno con le cellule staminali
messe dall'esterno ma lo fanno perché
hanno dei geni che gli consentono a
farlo un po di anni fa abbiamo detto ma
andiamo a cercarli questi geni andiamo a
cercare i quali sono i geni che
potrebbero fare rigenerare per esempio
il cuore di un uomo di un mammifero e
abbiamo pensato che questi geni devono
essere dei geni non convenzionali allora
il nostro patrimonio genetico contiene
circa 20.000 pezzi di informazione
quindi quelle che chiamiamo geni per
fare circa 20.000 proteine e questo è
quello che li la genetica classica
insegna ma da una decina d'anni noi
sappiamo che oltre a questi 20 mila geni
classici ce ne sono almeno duemila e
contengono l'informazione deve fare
delle proteine ma per fare dei piccoli
rna regolatori piccoli vuol dire che
sono veramente molto più piccoli 21 22
mattoncini li formano e si chiamano
micro rna allora siamo chiesti ma non
sarà che all'interno di questi duemila
micro rna ci sono qualcuni che riescono
a rimettere in moto la proliferazione
delle cellule del cuore quindi abbiamo
fatto questo
questa ricerca con uno screening
robotizzato e alla fine li abbia trovati
qualcuno che è in grado effettivamente
di far proliferare le cellule del cuore
in laboratorio e non soltanto in grado
di far proliferare le cellule del
laboratorio le cellule con il
laboratorio ma una volta messo nel cuore
le fa proliferare anche nel cuore questa
è stata una scoperta nuova perché in
qualche maniera ci dà la possibilità di
pensare in maniera diversa allora
pensate un paziente con infarto del
miocardio cosa succede di questo
paziente che se fortunato di vivere le
nostre società viene portato rapidamente
in ospedale e se vi va in un'unità
coronarica entro tre quattro ore dal
momento dell'infarto al prima arriva
meglio ecco che il cardiologo entra con
un catetere nella sua arteria coronaria
per un palloncino e ripristina la
pervietà delle arterie coronarie rimuove
l'ostruzione ma tutto quello che è morto
in queste due tre quattro ore è qualcosa
che è destinato a non ricrescere a non
riformarsi ma essere sostituito da una
cicatrice
immaginate ora di avere questo stesso
paziente che
quando viene diagnosticato dell'infarto
gli viene iniettato dopo qualche giorno
dal momento in cui ha avuto riaperta da
tele krona rya uno di questi micro rna
che stimolano le sue cellule cardiache a
crescere a fare un effetto salamandra
cioè a moltiplicarsi coke la sua
cicatrice invece di formarsi sarà
sostituita dal nuovo tessuto contrattile
che potrà in qualche maniera
accompagnarlo in una migliore vita
tutto molto bello farlo su i disegnini
però più difficile farlo in vivo però di
fatto questa cosa funziona nel piccoli
animali per esempio se voi fate un
infarto a un topolino agli iniettate uno
di questi micro rna invece più e
formarsi delle grandissime cicatrici sul
cuore si vengono a formare delle
piccolissime cicatrici perché il resto
del tessuto cardiaco è stato rimpiazzato
dal nuovo tessuto contrattile il nuovo
il cuore del topo è qualcosa di così
piccole il cuore dell'uomo è molto più
grande e difficile passare dalla
sperimentazione sul topo la
sperimentazione sull'uomo
ci vuole un modello di animale che sia
più vicino all'uomo questo modello di
animale nelle malattie cardiovascolari e
sostanzialmente rappresentato dal maiale
ecco allora che faccio vedere dei
risultati che per noi sono molto molto
eccitanti ottenuti con una tecnologia
che permette di vedere il cuore come
funziona invii voce dei filmini cui
danno un'idea della contrazione
cardiache in vivo ottenuti a pisa la
scuola sant'anna con la risonanza
magnetica nucleare ero qui sopra è un
cuore infartuato il cerchietto che con
molta difficoltà vedete si contrae il
ventricolo sinistro ma è un triplo
sinistro un mese dopo l'infarto è già
molto dilatato vedete la parete e molto
molto sottile e molto di sé cinetico si
muove abbastanza abbastanza male e
quindi questo sotto invece è un maiale
che è stato iniettato subito dopo un
infarto simile buon un micro rna che
stimo nella rigenerazione cardiaca voi
intuitivamente senza essere cardiologi
potete immediatamente vedere che questo
ventricolo rimane più piccolo non c'è
dilatazione del cuore non c'è scommesso
cardia con la parete è più spessa e la
contrazione è più efficace
riusciremo a portare questa cosa la
clinica beh ovviamente il nostro sogno
di ricercatori ed i medici ci sono
ancora molti ostacoli anche fra il
maiale la sperimentazione umana ma pian
piano stiamo cercando di recuperarli
però la cosa che a me piace di questo
tipo di ricerca e che segnano a via
nuova abbiamo passato dieci anni a
tormentarci con l'utilizzo delle cellule
staminali fra scandali nella l'opinione
pubblica e insuccessi nella comunità
scientifica
ecco che allora questo tipo di approccio
e un approccio che a me piace chiamarlo
rigenerazione dall'interno non mettiamo
più niente dall'esterno cerchiamo di
utilizzare i geni la funzione dei geni
per rimettere in moto spontaneamente la
macchina del cuore nel nostro caso
essere inceppata ma sono sicuro che
questo tipo di approccio possa essere
utilizzato anche per rigenerare il
pancreas generale l'occhio rigenerare
gli altri organi e forse se siamo
fortunati anche a rigenerare i nervi e
il cervello e con questo finito e vi
ringrazio molto per la nuotatrice
[Applauso]